I'm here with the amazing Catherine
Heigl okay so you recently celebrated a
birthday I did my birthday is the 24th
of November my daughters is the 23rd and
it's often on Thanksgiving the day
before Thanksgiving the day after
Thanksgiving it's just kind of a messy
week so it's chaos and like did you tell
your mom you wanted a birthday cake yeah
she's she's mean
she said no because she was making pies
for Thanksgiving and Thanksgiving is
pies not cake and I said but it's my
birthday and she said too bad that's you
know that was inconvenient of you to
choose to be born on Thanksgiving is it
like funny or are you like okay good
um okay you and your husband been buried
for 15 years in December congratulations
thank you that is absolutely I can't
quite believe it I can't I don't know
how we've made it this time how do you
think you made it this long I think
listen marriage is hard
um but the thing that I keep leaning
into again and again no matter how sort
of disconnected we may get how matter
how much traveling might start happening
no matter how many sort of um
miscommunications which is a big one I
think in marriage and um I tell my
daughters too like tone it's not always
what you say too it's how you say it 110
you're asking for something reasonable
but the way we're asking is really
hurting my heart very aggressive
um so aggressive but that's me I'm the
aggressive one I think that's obvious we
all know this
um you do have so much Moxie but it's
what we love about you too I'm just
older and bitter now and you've always
been so nice and fun to hang out with
but you have a really deep strength at
your core which is thank you very
admirable I also have a very very strong
mother and we're very close we talked
twice a day every day coffee and
Cocktails this is like and um
I don't think my girls will call me
twice a day every day where is Nelly
Nelly
it's my fear too I want that connection
with them for Life they're my everything
yeah friendship my female friendships
and I always show the girls how
important those are to me and that's why
I love Firefly Lanes so when absolutely
so tell us about season two of one of my
favorite shows oh thank you I'm so
grateful you like it I love it I'm so
proud of it I I love it too and I think
what I love about it is
um is the message is the story and I
fell in love with the book I'm a huge
Kristin Hannah fan so it was very
exciting to me to get to to be a part of
telling one of her stories and um Sarah
chalk is like
I mean Sarah will be your best friend
and it makes it a thousand times easier
and it was so
fun and I felt so safe with Sarah and it
makes it so fun to watch
um we have a clip from the latest season
uh oh good death row activists protest
outside Duffy's prison death row
activist protest outside Duffy's prison
death row activist protest outside
Duffy's prison raised in awareness they
know I'm not Southern can't smile
bigger just a little bit bigger keeps a
bit more teeth a little bit more more
teeth more teeth
and there's nothing better when you can
work with your friends oh yeah because
then all your sound families come
together okay the last time you were
here we chatted about your charity which
means so much to me because it's
dedicated to your brother you do it with
your mother as well you recently
launched a new program yes tell us about
that well I recently launched a brand
it's um I'm passionate about it because
when it will help us continue to fund
the foundation so the food is such a
blessing and that it will help us to
continue to do that and you're coming
out with dog food that yeah it is out
yes it's out it's out okay I'm buying it
immediately because I was it's already
e-commerce it's all online it's not in
stores I was reading about the integrity
and the ingredients and I'm really
passionate about that I'm like super I'm
kind of wishing my dogs all the herbs
and plant medicine I like making
tinctures so I was able to incorporate
some of that
sort of holistic plant medicine into the
food to address well I see so many
issues especially with all these animals
coming out of the shelter I know
um Switching gears a little bit uh if
you don't mind this is a new thing we're
doing can I kick it off with you yes
three recommendations to head into our
weekend with our latest segment kicked
off by Patrick
that sounds good you should have me do
it every day
you can tell us what you could would uh
recommend to eat
um I'm a big spaghetti bolognese fan ah
yeah all right number two it's the
holidays we're all freaking out like on
every site and trying to get those gifts
together do you have any recommendations
for an easy holiday gift I have one that
I love so much and I gave to everybody
last year and everyone liked it which is
you know they're called fazzal Socks
f-a-z-l-e I love socks they're the Cozy
wool hand knit socks by these wonderful
beautiful women in India and a portion
of the proceeds goes to orphans and I
felt like
um win on every level so okay we're
gonna put this on Instagram this clip so
we can push to that okay uh last um is
there anywhere you think is a good place
to have a first date at my age right now
I'd be like make it quick
maybe Starbucks
you know
premieres today on Netflix
[Music]